when Russian troops closed in on the key
of suburb of European in February suraki
and Arena left their apartment
and fled
it was April before Russia abandoned its
push on Kiev and the family ventured
home again
when we were turned we found a burnout
kitchen and a shell Department
here are the remains of a cottage that
went through two walls but fortunately
did not catch fire
the place is uninhabitable but others
had it worse
just before Urban was liberated one of
the neighbors was killed and we weren't
allowed to bury him immediately his body
lay next to the other captured people
for several days and it was three days
later before he was buried in the yard
rebuilding has begun but herepin still
Bears deep scars at a mortar-damaged
sports club Sergey is back to his job
teaching kids football
he tells me these boys have been through
hell
like him many lost their homes and fled
but through the trauma and the turmoil
football was a constant
arasua
hello
wherever they are the boys look for both
is there relief and a way to distract
themselves football is their favorite
thing in life you can destroy homes and
stadiums but you cannot destroy their
love for football and their goal to
become football players
parents watch from the sidelines the war
goes on but this is a semblance of
normality at least
the children wanted to return home meet
the coach and their relatives as soon as
possible I think football is amazing
children need as much joy fun and time
with their friends as possible
and of course like Millions if not
billions of people around the world
their eyes are on the World Cup in Qatar
fortunately the national team hasn't
qualified for Qatar 2022 so there'll be
no Ukraine playing there in blue and
yellow but football is still helping
bring this traumatized and war-torn
Country back together
and the kids know who they're supporting
England my favorite team is Brazil Spain
my favorite team in England my favorite
country is Portugal
[Music]
Rory challenge Al Jazeera herepin
Ukraine